this is a production of cornell
university
today i'll present our recent work on
microbial ion interaction
to control ligand decomposition in soil
and
so so basically this piece of work is to
try to understand the mechanisms
the ligand decomposition
and what we did is we
analyzed a data set i published the data
sets
on the ligand decomposition
and
we basically we developed the iso called
microbial ion interaction model we call
me fee model
which on the right side
and
the model contains two major components
one is a carbon dynamic another is ion
in ion
reactions
so from the
right side of figure you can see
this a bigger big
solid black circle represents the
macro molecule lignin
and which is interact with the react i
reduce the ion
through so-called
fainting reactions
and then the big uh the macromolecule
ligand becomes smaller
molecule lignin as indicated by gray
smaller circle
and then there is a smaller
molecule lignin that can be utilized by
micro
and then the microbial circulate
generates a necroma
necromass which
together with a small
molecule lignin that can be
you know stabilized
to the
iron uh associated the carbon solution
called the com
composition
so on other hand the
the ion also change from
reduced phase to oxide oxidize the phase
and then this uh
oxidized phase under the
um can can
sequester carbon
on the throne that's
iron associated organic matter so that's
basically the model we developed
and
use that model to try to explain the
observe the pattern or stored on on the
left side
so our analysis basically draw the two
conclusion one is uh
you know mineral associated the organic
carbon actually is largely from
plant to derive the carbon at least of
what is a particular study
and the second is the ligand
decomposition is not driven by first
order
or
mechanism kinetics
but related to growth and the mortality
of microbial populations and the
community
the true conclusion actually has
contemporary
implications
because currently the
the
the paradigm
paradigm
on the my soil organic dynamic is
shifting
to
uh towards the
the concept that
mirror associated organic matter it's
currently more you know proposed
mostly derived from microbial residue
but this study indicates that
at least for these ligand decomposition
mostly derived
from plant derived carbon
the second conclusion also is kind of
has contemporary
implications because uh recently
a huge effort has put into
uh on
try to incorporate the microbial process
into earth system model those microbial
processes mainly based on the
microscopic equation and
and
but here is basically we used to
so-called the data-driven approach to
try to try to adjust those issues
so these people recently published in
soil
biology under biochemistry
so the whole project actually started in
our from our
third
training course
my lab has
has been running a
international training course on
new advances in land carbon cyclical
modeling since 2018
and to
you know up to now it's nearly 500
attendees from 40 nearly 40 countries
attended on the third training course
that's in 2020
we had an attendee
that's one gen um juan
and
a research associate from iowa state
she presented one data set
at that time she got the whole paper you
know
published by that time and she showed
that ligning
co2 well basically co2 release from a
ligament lignin decomposition
on the right side is a cumulative
co2 release on the right side
side
show the the panel showed the rate of
co2 release from a leading decomposition
particularly on the right side you can
see the the co2 release
from lignin decomposition has
as kind of a pattern it's a non-linear
pattern
this pattern is in
major is in big contrast with a
typical so-called the first order
kinetic decay
functions
and
my lab particularly interested in these
those patterns because that's a really
related to
to the biology of the decomposition
process and those biology potentially
can be incorporating the earth system
model
so things about probably nearly 20 years
ago
my lab tried to
kind of observe the patterns
reported in the literature in from all
kinds of studies
so so my lab has synthesized the
thousands of thousands of data sets to
show the how
how little
decomposition
and
occurs over time
and we synthesized about uh you know 2
000 data sets on little decomposition
almost all of them show that there is a
first order decay curve
and we also synthesize that you know
more than one thousand datasets on soil
uh organic carbon decomposition from uh
from your soil incubation studies
almost all of them also you know follow
this kind of accumulative patterns which
also can be described by first order
kinetics
and we also synthesized those
soil carbon dynamics over time during
the forest succession
and also during you know the cultivation
under the vertical profile
so so far my lab will try to synthesize
all kinds of data we
we we we can collect almost all of them
follow the first order kinetics
and but recently there are a
huge effort into
uh into the
incorporating
the the microbial process into the soil
organic decomposition model
and my student
the niche recently is you know just
reviewed the microbial explicit model
and he finds about 70 models
and especially those mods many of the
models developed recently
those models
incorporate like microbial decomposition
process mineral interactions
microbial mortality and active or
dormant
microbial
transitions
and also he showed that
all these microbial decomposition
most of them use a so-called necklace to
maintain kinetics some are some of them
use the reverse the nucleus kinetics and
a few
equilibrium and chemistry approximation
so majority of them are used to use the
you know non-linear mechanism kinetics
or reverse the mechanism the equation uh
kinetics
maintaining maintenance kinetics has
intrinsic non-linear dynamic
and we
you know
80 years ago
i organized a working group and
one of
working group member yin ping juan he
developed
a
well basically he analyzed the
mathematical property of those nucleus
cementing equation
the mix
if
a model has one or two necklacement
equations to dominate the uh the
decomposition process and then these you
think that
mathematically we will see the
oscillative patterns
and these oscillating patterns indicate
the basically due to that non-linearity
of
nonlinearity in the necklacement
equation
so i have been trying to
find the data sets to
to support those molecular submitting
equations for a long time so when i saw
the data assets presented by
uh wing gm huang
and during the workshop i was so excited
so the data sets on the right side
potentially can support these nucleus
maintenance equations and because so far
i haven't seen any data sets except this
one which potentially can support the
mechanism equation
so then we are we formed a so-called a
working group to work on that the
working group has
about
12 members
and
among them
the tai chi and leon i
led the model development and when jane
juan
she has original data and also has a
knowledge on little decomposition and
both of them
you know cool could collect
the working group
and then
so during the process i i also learned
about the ligand decomposition a lot and
from especially from winterfell one now
power as you know lignin
lignin is a big molecule
and
[Music]
all the
paradigm for soil organic matter dynamic
is
is based on so-called the lignin
dominated the soil organic matter and
the bio
biochemical recapturiness in the lignin
it's a it's a determinant
for the latest stage of a little
decomposition under the form so-called
organic matter so this is a so-called
humus
humorous uh uh concept you know
classical paradigm is a little
decomposition other than selectively
preserving those a bigger
bigger molecule and these uh this is a
kind of a classic or older paradigm
but
but the recently you know the more
modern paradigm emphasize that the stoic
microbial process and the lignin
liganding
is do you know does not persist in in
organic matter so the biochemical
recursion is is it's less important
but the microbial substrate use
efficiency and then
macro mass become more important so
that's the the concept uh the new new
concept
so
that's those basically i learned a lot
from uh during the working group
from especially from uh wintery of juan
and uh
and she she basically pointed out
recent evidence of hidden and the
persistent liganding because for these
uh
yeah these uh
these uh oxidized
uh
cubric
oxal
oxidation oxalate oxidation is
underestimate the ligand
content of
mineral soil
lignin derivative performancely
associated with iron and
alumini
minerals
so those uh fatal for lignin in soil
remain
uh it's a undetermined
and also
you know during the process i learned a
lot about the ligand
decomposition which require the ox
oxygen
and
and the the ion link the react
reactive oxygen species
can take
degraded lignin through so-called phyton
reactions
those are short-range the ordered
ion
faces the performance of preferentially
protected basically this kind of ion
associated to the organic matter so
i don't play the do do rule
in
lignite decomposition
so basic one is a stimulant
stim stimulating the
breakdown of a
macro molecule ligand into small
molecule but also these oxidized
ion protected
the protected this small molecule lignin
so so these uh this issue is
particularly important in those wealth a
wetland or it's a highly saturated
the areas as oxygen fluctuates
fluctuated in those tropical rainforest
corporate or wetland
and then variability in oxygen in the
book soil under the micro science may
drive uh
the ion re redox cycling
so
so the crew i mean the lab she is is
steve hall
in iowa state the university
and they design the experiment they try
to control the the amount of reduced ion
in the soil
by manipulating the uh the so-called an
anaerobic period so they use the
use the um
ice
isotope the label the synthetic lignin
to chase the lignin decomposition
they applied anaerobic conditions
at the beginning of the the study so
they have four treatment one is a
control which all have anaerobic uh uh
aerobic uh anaerobic condition
and then they have controlled the
anaerobic uh
condition for fourth day eighth day
under 12 days
and then they they by doing that they
they created a different amount of uh
reduce the ion and to see how that's
influenced in ligand decomposition they
used the soil incubation uh approach the
experiment to do that so these results
you already seen this
those are the results they observed from
the experiment you can see that
um the
the zero day basically control has
lowest the
lowest uh
co2 release rate
and the 12 days
a treatment has a highest
steel to release the rate
this is because of
the highest
uh
highest level
of
reduced
io
so
so this
uh assimilation that there is a pattern
observe that the decomposition rate
pattern from a little
ligand decomposition is quite different
from traditional first order kinetic
decay decay pattern so so then we
we developed a
model
which we use the so-called first order
kinetics we also use the the mechanism
kinetics and we also use the so-called
logistic function
logistical function
we develop that logistic function purely
because of the data so because we use
the mercury equation we use the first
order and the normal
can fit the data well so then we try the
different functions the tools to see how
we can best reduce reproduces the
observations so end up
either under logistic functions is the
best of the best function to describe
the the observer pattern
so here is the
the model we developed we use the matrix
form to
describe the
the decomposition process
so dx over dt is the
is that that
x here means the carbon
and uh so we use the two equation one is
represented by kobe activity another
equation to represent the how ion
and
interact with the carbon processes
so we also have a ion model
at the bottom of these slides
so
we use the so-called data data driven
approach
data-driven approach is basically we use
these uh
user the data to see
to
to select the best model
alternative model structure
and then once we
we selected the best alternative
structure we use the data assimilation
to estimate the the
parameter you know best
uh best
likely most likely hold us the parameter
and then we in this way
we we try to see what the mechanisms
underline the little decomposition
so model structure
seriously is to simulate a little
decomposition process
parameter estimate estimation is to
inform us how much primitive
variance at the different pre-treatment
on the model we use the model prediction
to evaluate the rule of geochemical
content
and
on the biochemical processing control
ligand phase in the soil
so here is the estimated parameter
for the different process so however the
top panel is for control second
panel is a four day eight day and 12
days and in this figure you can see
these uh if this
you know in each for the each of the
parameter
if this
shape is alone that means the data
didn't provide enough information to
constrain them if it loses
those symbols of very
uh you know have a small range that
that means that data have
more information to constrain those
parameters
and
once we
constrain those parameters we evaluate
how well they fit
from this figure you can see
we have a three type of model
the first one
and let me see what's in the color
the probably the blue
blue color
is the first order kinetics
greenish color is a formula cementing
equation
red color is the
methi model with a logistic equation
and
the the dot
uh dot with the these
indicated the data so we have a four uh
uh four treatment
control four day eight day and twelve
day you can see in the old treatment
there was a meaty model with logistic
equation uh fit the data best
on that at the bottom of the bottom
at the bottom that the table indicates
all those statistics related to the r
square
and the
rmse and
m a
p e so those are indicate
the model fitting
once we fit the model we try to use the
estimated parameter to understand the
mechanisms
uh
underline the ligand decomposition
so our analysis indicates that
differential
co2 production among the treatment it's
a primary ex can be
explained by various in the initial
carbon
and the iron pull sides
and also the carbon transfer rate and
the microbial uptake rate
the initial value of
reduced
ion
increases with anaerobic treatment
duration of treatment
and that's consistent with the
experimental observation
the greater initial value of a small
molecule in the longer
the anaerobic pre-treatment and
and that's basically results lead to the
stronger liganding
uh
depor myerization
so here we us the phase of lignan carbon
you can see the macro
ligand and carbon in decline over the
time
but end of the experiment which is
almost about one year
you can see about half of the macro
molecules still remain about half of
them already converted or released
and this uh this is a 12 days of
pre-treatment has the lowest value
by an angle for the treatment this is a
small molecule
a liganding procedure initially it's
quite high and towards the end it's
depleted because all those small
molecules has
has been associated with ion in the in
in the so-called the
m-o-m-m-a-o-o-n
and
microbial carbon has a very very dynamic
transition initially it's low and then
gets very high and then depleted
and those uh protect the carbon it's
also it's initially very low and towards
the end it's quite a high
and with 12 days this protected the
carbon has a highest amount
so
by end of
this experiment
we see that most of iron protected the
carbon was derived from
small molecule leading ligand carbon
it's only it's about
only about three percent of
uh ion protected the carbon derived from
microbial residue
so overall we we developed a
leafy model
and uh try to explain uh try to
understand the mechanisms underline the
ligand decomposition so these different
more the the modeling uh analysis
indicate that uh
you know the first order under the
nicholas mention
kinetics
cannot explain the pattern well
but the the
leafy model was a logistic equation
which indicated time independent time
dependent growth and mortality
of
microbial population that community
probably is the main mechanisms to
to underline the the co2 release
so nearly half of the lignan carbon
is preserved as ion associate the
organic carbon
by angle for the experiment certainly
this experiment has a lot of limitations
it only lasts for one year
and if longer whether it's a more
microbial
microbial
associate the carbon being preserved or
not these issues need to be further
explored in the future
and
um so so basically these data indicate
this nucleus and kinetics still cannot
describe the co2 release from ligand
decomposition at least based on the data
we used
so this is what i have and i'm happy to
take any questions
okay oh yeah johannes
i was wondering um i didn't quite catch
how the lignin was analyzed you
mentioned at some point it was difficult
to extract it in the first place i
imagine that any
any lignin derivatives
that are absorbing to iron oxides might
be difficult to extract
or impossible to extract and coperic
oxide oxidation
is is maybe not even the way to go um i
yeah so i i was wondering could it be
that these are microbial metabolites
that are
re-metabolized i know that dan is
working a lot in in in uh different
communities metabolizing that you get
successive humps of
of um co2 production from ver various
products that still bear maybe c13
signals from the original lignin but are
are not lignin anymore
thanks
well it's a great question um
i may not be the best person to answer
this question about the liganding you
know the
as as i mentioned that we only developed
the model try to explain
and that the one co-author actually the
you know equal contributor
that when you
uh when you're juan uh is the person who
made the measurements
uh yeah i
i'm
i have to admit i am not the right
person to answer those questions about
the measurements
sorry about that
oh we have a question from zoom harold
please don't meet yourself
yes hi um how you seek can you hear me
yes okay great well thanks for the for
the great uh seminar presentation um so
i have a comment and a question so um my
comment is that you know when we do soil
health analyses which are you know a
little bit more broad
um and that includes extracting
nutrients but also with that we extract
iron and manganese and and we uh we very
consistently see
higher um
iron extracted and i i assume that's
iron too
um
uh when we see you know when it's like
no-till soils or whether organic
amendments have added been added or or
um or cover crops so that the healthier
soils also seem to be higher in iron too
which i think would be explained by by
your work um
that's the way i interpreted it but the
the other like i said the other uh
element that sort of comes up a lot is
manganese
and uh and so my understanding and i'm
not a soil chemist by any means is that
manganese
has sort of similar um involvement in
the decomposition of
of
recalcitrant organic compounds so can
you can you comment on on the manganese
issue
again i um
harold it's a great question
and uh
you know i
i have to admit i'm not soil as a
chemist so or soil scientists
and uh this is just the opportunity from
uh
you know the data sets came from the
training training course and we
developed the model
yeah i i have a lot to learn about soil
chemists
and uh sorry
this is the second question i cannot
fully answer yeah
thanks anyway
yeah um okay um
while waiting for others uh to raise
their hand i have a question in terms
from the modeling side um
so
yeah i think the general strategy is to
make the model uh to match the
observation
but maybe most of the time we match the
observation but for the wrong mechanism
so how to ensure
we get the mechanism representation
right we get the the struct model
structure right and the parameter
parameters right
uh so
and also how to make sure
the model not only match the current
observation but also match it sees a
long term trend and also variability in
a much longer time scale
this is a great question and
that's
yeah this is a very very um
important question
in modeling
um
it's true
if uh you know we can't develop a model
for one particular data set
and the model may fit
that particular data sets well but they
may not represent the general mac
the
mechanism that can be generalized over
time or over the other data sets
and this is a great point
what we did is you know before before we
formed the working group i
was really concerned
about this issue
so i talked with uh
you know dr juan lot
and asked her that question how
representative your data sets
and she
she
she's
you know she assured me that
that her data set is relatively new
and
it's not many of them hasn't been
published
but they she she basically gave me a
sense
they did the
measurement
very rigorously
and they also
you know steve hall published that paper
in the following year
in um
ecology i think steve
reviewed a variety of
data sets
so so so this is a very critical issue
yeah it's a it's all it's a it's a very
risk or dangerous
just a random i mean the randomly pick
one data set to develop for one model
and
we decided to develop a model it's you
know getting
to get
assurance from her author
second is she uh she also pointed to us
that
ligand composition is a major issue
uh use you know soil organic dynamic
and
the data sets it's a
relatively
new certainly i you know i i
again i don't have the knowledge to make
it make a judgment
about that i i just i trusted her
judgment that probably you know many um
some of the audiences
may know know this much better than me
and
so
so and also as i mentioned this is just
the incubation data
you know
the the incubation experiment only
lasted for one year
and those those conclusions are very
tentative and only limited within that
that that
experiment under that experimental
condition
okay great thank you
any other questions
from the room
hi thank you so much for your
presentation i have a question on one of
the graphs it has
squirrels on it and i was wondering if
you can explain that really quickly i've
never seen a graph like that
okay i'll i'll share the screen again
you may
make
let me see if
you mean
you mean the model
like this
um
it's towards the beginning
i think maybe uh professor you won that
diary
it's uh infused diagram
you want that one
yeah yeah i think yeah
okay
what's the um
can you can you ask your question again
um can you explain what that shows i've
never seen a graph like that
okay
um
i'm not sure
how many uh if any of you you know that
have a
tech ecology uh based ecology like 101
in the
ecology usually talked about the
pre-predator
model this is you know this is a
lot of theorem model
preparated the model usually has this
pattern so the pattern basically show
this on x-axis is my
microbial biomass
and the y-axis is a soil organic carbon
when
when
when we use nucleus melting equation
the
microbial biomass on the soil organic
matter biomass basically influence that
the rate of decomposition
coupled because they made a carport in
such a way that formed the oscillative
support of
oscillation so so this figure is
basically
uh
replot
the data on the panel uh
panel you know the two panels above
so so this is oscillating
dumping oscillations so that's indicate
i understand that is probably it's
another very satisfactory
explanation
thank you and uh i once i get back
probably i can explain to you
in more detail
okay thank you so much
thanks thanks great question
yeah we have one more question here
hello um
my name is annette i'm working with
johannes thank you very much for your
talk it was very informative
i have a um
i have a question concerning the
experiments were they anaerobic over the
whole 360
days
or does this reaction with iron also
occur when you have oxygen in the system
and how realistic is it that in the soil
we really have an inorganic
degradation of lignin
and again and
it's a great question and
again probably uh i i may not know the
experiment
well enough to answer your question well
and i'm really sorry this uh
you know the uh liganding decomposition
so your chemistry so your geochemistry
is it's not really
uh i'm still learning picking up and i
can pass your question to
to
to school author and uh professor the
one and then to try to answer your
question
i'm sorry
okay thank you my my limitation
yeah i mean i could um could read the
papers but my time is kind of
yeah yeah
okay i check it thank you
thank you
this is the my limits my limit of
the limits of my knowledge yeah
well this is the way you're in sips now
so we all learn from each other we learn
from experimentalists and uh we're
modellers they're trying to incorporate
the mechanistic understanding to our uh
into our models and also try to use
models to
uh help like a better design of the
experiment so it's going to be an
iterative and two-way process
uh
any other questions from the room
no
okay yeah thank you very much uh
professor law uh and we all look forward
to your uh coming back from china and
talk to you in person thank you
thank you thank you all and i'm sorry
again and i'll i'll see you in next week
yeah on campus
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu